et missile ukrainien en territoire russe
dimanche matin plusieurs missiles ont
touché le village russe dessous MK une
dizaine de kilomètres de la frontière
Russo ukrainienne le bombardement a fait
quatre morts selon le gouverneur de
cette région déjà victime début mars
d'une attaque semblable
la veille une autre frappe sur des
positions russes en crimées avait
déclenché un incendie à Sébastopol
l'attaque n'a pas été revendiquée mais
elle pourrait être attribuée à l'Ukraine
une forme de réponse à la mort d'au
moins 26 Ukrainiens dont des enfants
lors d'une attaque russe dans la ville
de oumans plutôt dans la semaine
le président volody mirzelanski avait
promis des représailles ce dimanche il a
surtout rappelé l'imminence d'une grande
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui selon
lui dépend grandement de l'aide
occidentale
pour être honnête les avions de combat
F16 aideraient beaucoup mais il est
clair que nous ne retarderons pas la
contrefensive nous la commencerons avant
d'avoir les F16 si nous n'allons pas
dire aux Russes qu'ils ont encore
quelques mois devant eux le temps que
l'on s'entraîne sur les avions non ça ne
se passera pas comme ça nous
commencerons et nous irons de l'avant
la Russie continue de pilonner les
villages Ukrainiens elle revendique de
nouvelles avancées à barmut mais face à
la menace d'une contre-offensive elle
vient de remplacer son chef de la
logistique militaire
logistique souvent défaillante depuis le
début